[Music]  is  [Music]  [Music]  commercial  [Music]  right now we can spend a whole day if  you like it you catch one tuna  [Music]  so we need to go back to that mentality  please  take what you need not what you want  the definition of a good fisherman is  not somebody who  successfully goes out there and harvests  everything but a successful fisherman is  somebody who goes out there  and takes care of the ocean  when  my  the benefits from that one conservation  area  is multiple  that fish is worth more alive  for us to remain this way for the future  and for our young people we have to  ensure we  help preserve  [Music]  [Music]  m  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you